why use a blue colored board no there's
a default board is something I really
haven't changed board theme yeah I feel
like other colors are a bit more
distracting like this just hurts my eyes
about this yeah good live with purple
I'm gonna keep this yeah some colors are
not meant to exist yeah what is decent
I'm just used to this think ideally you
just want something that you're used to
that's not too distracting Oh is there
3d I could play a game on the 3d board
board theme
wait no for geometry 3d oh dear oh dear
why is growing up there's a program what
was it called Chessmaster 9000 and i
would play like on the 3d board on an
interface try pre moves can I change the
color that there's not enough contrast
is there a piece set for 3d oh there is
Wow kudos to me chess having a dynamic
dynamic set up mmm too much saturation
[Music]
not enough contrast to green random blue
in red mmm not happy with these okay
this is actually probably the best
okay I'll play a light one blitz game on
the 3d board oh it's it's almost
overhead but it's kind of tilted okay
let's try this new opponents
yeah the background could be changed but
hold off wow it's like it's like over
the board chess opponents so afraid huh
anyway um yeah if you're just joining
I'm running a Swiss tournament starting
in 20 minutes okay playing boomerang
okay boomerang tog you can't join Oh
someone help tog II because I'm kind of
preoccupied I feel like the I'm I feel
seasick or motion sickness the
perspective seems off like it kind of it
I don't know okay but I'm playing a
London it's still okay it's interesting
yeah I'm just like just not used to this
I pre move Wow and it's so
three-dimensional yes oh I can draw
arrows to arrows go under the piece
fascinating so see for ya see for the
knight spin when I draw I can make it
red mm-hmm that's a move I probably have
to take so I could play I can play this
move Queen Queen a four and then there's
rook c8 takes
takes b3 maybe let's try it
being aggressive Oh does not work on
phones uh-oh
like the Swiss feature we are you trying
to use it in the app you should be able
to use it if you're on if you're just in
a mobile browser it should be okay but
yeah tog II don't you have like a your
other tablet right with some kind of
device type of perspective is isometric
whatever that means
okay I like the structure though I don't
have to play c5 I could mean though I
have the two bishops I should probably
castle first the rise Bishop d3 could
have been annoying I'm scared about
getting into like a a time scramble
situation because I don't know if I'll
be so quick on a 3d board okay I want to
play h3 probably c5 at some points
that's a move play h3
Taji multitasking yes I'm also
multitasking between chats and playing
this a kinky seven yeah King g7 decent
move
maybe that six is coming f6
a three maybe
where's my night man that wants to be on
on b6c okay let's play c5 I'm gonna play
very prophylactically I'm gonna stop
black from playing E 5 bring the knight
back and put the rook here and g5 may be
expected
ooh that's weird the bish that about to
make any sense I dragged the bishop it
was under the pot and it's same thing
with a knight oh let's play I want to
play rook a3 oh that wants to play this
interesting play g4 okay three no I want
to play rook e1 I feel like it's much
easier to Mouse slip turkey one constant
pressure against this pawn bishop be
flogged good move
this is terrifying like it takes me a
little bit of extra time to like
internalize each move it was like 3d
board not used to move let's trade
bishops he's so slow to in this way I'm
actually kind of fast unexpected let's
go
I want it okay that was a that wasn't
easy it was hard to to make moves
I was interesting though yeah but there
were there were a few things what was it
when I moved the the night well I moved
the night back we analyzed or was it
when I move the bishop
yeah like when you drag the bishop it
kind of disappears under the night it
should be the I don't know it should be
the frontmost layer I don't know how
that's possible that was fun though I
don't think I'll do it again but yeah
that was like what to compare that to
kind of like skydiving like slightly
thrilling slightly terrifying you just
do it once so you can say that you did
it okay let's let's switch it back to
normal board 2d yes okay all is so much
better Queen b6 pretty sure this isn't
my prep somewhere no c4 is a move a six
oh so I should just take if Queen takes
95
yeah 95 24 looks strong or just casting
huh if takes as it's still kind of a new
opening for me we take the beat to how
Queen a for winning wow that's a cool
idea Queen d7 rook a or rook F b1 and
say you're okay B 1 because if takes
takes the Queen's tied down to the pawn
queen see a rook be six massive
compensation it's a very cool line why
are you using 3d pieces yeah never mind
I think someone told me to I was just
curious but yeah I don't think I'll be
doing that's too often
anyway um yeah thanks for the game was
that YouTube worthy maybe maybe I'll put
that on YouTube 3d chess in a 2d world